I've got a son he's 6 I want to be best
friends with him I want to be pals with
him why is that so wrong no that's fine
you can be friendly with him but if you
think that's your only role as a parent
then I feel sorry for you because in the
end your son won't want to be friends
with you what your son needs is love
care support and you can provide that
support for him by establishing rules
and routines within your house which in
the end will mean a lot more for him
than just being a friend you will by
being a parent be modeling what it means
to be a man to be a parent he'll be able
to copy you when hopefully one day he's
a parent but just being a friend to your
son is really a road to hell but can you
both can you not be a friend and be
strict yeah you can as that's absolutely
fine I mean that's what most most good
parents try to do but in the end you
need to prioritize being a parent and
what that means and sometimes of course
it means not being a friend and Jennifer
House co-founder of Brit mums do you
have to have one without the other can
you be a parent and a best friend for
example absolutely it's eminently
sensible parents need to set limits they
need to make kids eat their vegetables
and do their homework but we've come a
long way from the Victorian
authoritarian parenting dad and we've
got numbers all over the UK and they all
say they want to have that close engaged
relationship with their kids sometimes
it's important to have that moment with
your child where you're not giving them
rules you're not correcting them you're
just enjoying each other's company and
getting to know them and isn't it mixed
signals I just wonder you know I had
quite traditional relationship with my
parents they're probably now my best
friends now I'm older when I was a child
they were definitely my parents and I'd
have found it quite confusing if they're
trying to be my best mate one minute and
then as soon as I do something they go
hold on a second and try and discipline
me I probably would have found that
quite confusing well you don't have to
relinquish your authority just because
you're being friendly with your with
your child I think that's probably a
better way to think about it as being
friendly with your child rather than
friends
you're not appear you're always still
you could be playing in the park if they
start to run out onto the street you'll
stop them so it is that that balance but
absolutely
being the parent first has to come yeah
Jackie you've got older children there
are teenagers so when they're that age I
would imagine you do become friends with
them because you start to have common
interests but the battles are greater
because they have their own opinion it's
and it's much more of a tough argument
so I'm about to become very unpopular in
my house because my son's about to DCS
he's so I'll be camped over his shoulder
to make sure he does X number of hours
revision every day and he might say oh
it's fine mom it's fine I've done it you
know if I was a friend I'd go okay but I
won't be saying okay I'll say no do a
bit more so I think there's lots of
families good cop and bad cop and often
the mum is the the Nike bad cop person
and the dad ends up being me the fun guy
I mean maybe that's the point you you
wanted the general point I'm making is
that the boys are doing quite badly in
this country you know at GCSE boys do
much worse than girls and we need to ask
the reason you know why is that is that
that they're less intelligent or is it
actually that they're rather immature
and you know we all know that no girls
are much more mature at the age of 16
and boys are and that's true I mean you
know girls women reach full maturity in
terms of their brainpower at the age of
about 22 but for young men it's about 30
look at last year's University Entrance
figures you know only just over a third
of boys doctor University but nearly
half of girls is a huge and growing gap
why is that happening what is because
boys aren't being disciplined enough in
in school and at home and they're being
allowed to do what they want to do which
is to fall behind that's quite
interesting isn't it you know boys need
a strong role model and with that as
what I was saying comes the discipline
comes knowing the boundaries because
children particularly they go into
teenage years will push those boundaries
and some parents if they want to have
that friendly relationship with their
child might let those boundaries sort of
edge and an edge was Jackie was saying
it's a constant battle I have a young
teen myself and constantly every I can
say the sky is blue and often she will
disagree so yeah there is that that
constant battle I think we need to
remember though for with children
not it's not an equation it's not good
discipline plus love equals perfect
child that you do have to tailor what
you're doing with your child for what's
going to motivate them what's gonna help
them in school what's gonna help them be
the person you want them to be who they
want to be themselves bond we have got a
huge amount of time left but you've
spent a long time in education a long
time seeing children seeing children
with their parents what advice would you
give given what you've seen in terms of
the lack of discipline now amongst boys
what advice would you give to fathers I
would say first of all remember that
there's no contradiction between you
know loving your children and being firm
and secure with them and establishing
rules and you know supporting your wife
in that respect remember that children
on the whole like rules and discipline
you know I've been a schoolteacher most
of my life and children say to me or
young adults say to me now I'm so
grateful that when you taught me you
were strict because I was by nature lazy
like most teenage boys and the fact that
you forced me to do work has now enabled
me to be the success that I am parents
need to realize that that children not
only need these secure rules but
actually they quite like them don't be
afraid
in other words of of taking control and
you know I I spoke to a parent the other
day ice and who's whose child was
spending too much time on a on a
Playstation and I said well why don't
you just take this PlayStation away
really they said no you know can I do
that groceries yeah you're a parent you
can do that yeah